what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to the lead attorney
talking about a child custody case the
reason that i'm reacting to this today
is because i don't think that it is very
well known especially amongst women just
how bad the system is rigged against men
the second reason that i'm reacting to
this today is because i want to get him
on my channel
and he keeps telling me we don't have
the same viewers
but we do i could see what anyways
um i'm gonna steal some just by
continuing to react to his content
and then get him on the channel i'm not
good at taking no for an answer it's not
a strong suit of mine
anyways okay let's go need to feed these
young men this information now what have
we got what is la's situation he has
three kids three daughters that's a
handful for his three daughters he was
paying child support that's normal right
well listen to what he did he went to
custody court at the custody court he
fought for joint legal joint physical
custody and guess what he won somehow he
won that's awesome man this is generally
what you need to be asking for if your
circumstances allow it in fact i think
that this should be the default in every
case now should every case always be
joint physical custody no there are
cases where father should not have it
and there okay it blows my mind that
it's not the default
it doesn't make any sense we want equal
rights don't we ladies
ladies in the chat we want equal rights
let's be equal come on there are cases
where mothers should not have each case
should be looked at on an individual
basis but but in every case the starting
point should be 50 50. no child support
each parent takes care of the children
when they're at his or her home the idea
that mothers are naturally better
parents than fathers is baseless and
it's demeaning to the huge role that
fathers play in children's lives to
automatically give a man visitation with
his own children is outrageous luckily
there are states like florida like
california where la is in that are being
more flexible they're coming around come
to atlanta and try to get that 50 50
custody maybe our conservative judges
will change in a decade or two but for
now you can generally forget about it
also and here is a lead attorney legal
lesson notice that there's not just one
justice system in the nation the justice
that you receive as a father will depend
so much on the state that you're living
in fathers get treated one way in
atlanta another way in new york another
way in san diego and then another way in
miami that's so crazy that it is so
based on luck
like where you happen to live
my
home state is illinois i can't imagine
it's good we people do not have nice
things to say
about any government system in illinois
it's usually negative
like 99 of the time think about that for
a second the access that you have to
your own children can depend on what
part of the country those children live
in it's amazing the arbitrary things
that control some of the most important
things of your life but that's just food
for thought getting back we've got a
great father who has fought for and won
joint legal joint physical custody of
his three daughters what does that mean
in terms of child support it means that
it's stopped he's no longer paying it's
a done deal he beat the child support
system so you say lean attorney what's
going on you said this video was about
child support this man's not even paying
child support why are you making this
video why are you saying that this video
is so important yeah i hear you let's
see what's going on okay what's up y'all
this is an update on my child support
situation i didn't went through custody
court and the conclusion was this child
support stopped i got joined legal
physical custody of my three daughters
child support stopped
it did and
i kid you not
right after it stopped the first chance
my ex got to get back on welfare cash
aid she did it she told him people that
i wasn't around
she had the kids and
i wasn't around didn't even tell him
that we had a custody agreement oh okay
that is the one thing that the
manosphere has taught me
these female oh my gosh
i mean okay i obviously knew
like there are shitty people out there
right but i did not realize how many
women
use children
to take advantage of men like kids lives
that's crazy to me i was always taught
do not get pregnant it will ruin your
life if it's not with the right person
and you're not married and stuff but
i've come to find out that these kids
are checks
to people
no remorse
none
i always thought these people were just
irresponsible
no oh what do we have here a little
welfare fraud after the child support
stops the mother has much less income
now she can't afford to live so what
does she do does she go out and get a
job like you or me no she applies for
government aid now listen members of the
jury there is nothing wrong with
government aid i have lived in a country
with no government aid and you do not
want to live in a nation like that this
aid is a huge help and life can be so
rough any one of us can find ourselves
needing that helping hand don't ever
look down on anyone on government aid
it's a blessing that is there what you
can and should look down on though is
the fraud that this lady used to get the
aid why lie tell the truth and let the
government decide whether or not you
qualify but no she didn't do that she
told the government that la was not
around told the government that she had
the kids so what did the government do
did they do their own investigation no
they didn't even take the time to run
her name through the system to see if
she had been to court over those kids if
they had they would have seen the whole
custody case they would have seen how la
had joint legal joint physical custody
of the children they just took her word
for it why would she lie now the
government thinks that la has abandoned
his responsibilities as a father so what
do they do so i got a letter
from child support so that they was
gonna start they was gonna reopen the
case on a certain day i had to appear in
court
to talk to the judge about it jesus oh
yeah the government's on the case now
they have issued him a citation saying
that they are reopening the child
support case that is reopening the same
child support case that they just closed
remember a judge had already ordered
that he stopped paying child support the
judge ordered that because he won joint
custody of the children now they are
going back to reopen it because they
think he's not around now that's crazy
they're rewarding her for lying
if you lie should shouldn't you get in
trouble that should be illegal
illegal throughout this video you will
see how la makes one great decision
after another first he fights to get
joint custody and wins then they tell
him that they're gonna reopen the case
if he doesn't show up and explain why
they shouldn't now you are thinking that
it's obvious that he should show up and
fight the case well you would be
surprised at how many people ignore
letters from the court requesting that
they appear they just ignore it or they
show up a month later because they
didn't see the letter oh my god that
happened to me one time wait he's gonna
say letter in the mail
that happened to me one time oh my gosh
and then i ended up getting my license
suspended because i didn't go to the
court
don't
and but i didn't see the letter
i didn't try to break the law i'm just
irresponsible god damn got the dates all
confused they missed the hearing but not
our man l.a bright and early on time he
shows up to court to clear up the
mistake he's doing everything right i go
to court she was there she was there let
me jump in right quick listen he had a
child support case they closed it
because he got joint custody of his
three daughters now the ex lied to get
it reopened but it's a pretty immature
lie because there's a court order
showing that la's got joint custody of
the kids so all la has to do is show up
and tell the judge about the custody
order then the judge will reclose the
child support case it's easy case closed
so you say lead attorney he's not paying
any child support anymore what's the big
deal why the video i hear you let's see
what happens i go to court she was there
and the judge was pretty much saying
what could
what could i afford to pay and i'm like
we have we have
a joint custody you know 55th and the
judge was like well
i'm not the the original judge i'm just
sitting in
but based on what you what's going on
today i think about it i make i make my
decision and you'll get it in writing
all right let me stop right here
remember when i told you that you could
get different treatment based on which
state you live in you will also get
different treatment based on the
different judges within your state you
members of the jury might think that the
outcome of the most important case of
your life will not depend on who sits in
a particular chair that day every single
attorney knows different in fact
attorneys often fight and scheme to try
to get their case how crazy is that
the eyes of the law changes
based on who's presiding over your case
i guess it's common sense in in some
ways
but
you like to think that
you know there's some consistency with
the law i don't know in front of a
particular judge we have all done it
it's so important now la tells this
judge that it's all a misunderstanding
it's really a fraud but
there's a court order saying that he's
got 50 50 custody of his three daughters
what does the judge say she's like i
don't know about all that i'm not the
original judge i'm just sitting in all i
want to know is how much can you afford
to pay and the judge was pretty much
saying what could
what could i afford to pay my question
is why don't you know about the custody
order you're a judge in the system where
the custody order was issued the file is
online check the file it's right there
the judge won't do it why not because
even though it's the same system there
are different parts within the system
they make it all separate to confuse
there's child support and there's
custody and even though they're linked
they separate them out so even though he
has an order saying that he has joint
custody the judge does not want to look
at it are you seeing how this works but
whatever
why
it doesn't make sense can't can they
check the other system
huh you know our man la he came prepared
he showed up to court with his paperwork
with the custody order he gave it to the
judge so she could read it he explains
to the judge about the custody order
even though she doesn't want to look at
it so i explained to the judge
we went through all this custody thing
and i bring the custody order and all
that gave her the custody order
and i'm like your honor
i do what i i supposed to do with my
daughters i'm a father to my kids
they know me it's not like
like i don't see them i don't have them
i'm like we spend our time together so i
told the judge and i'm like yeah it
ain't like i'm doing i'm not doing my
part
and and just like uh huh yeah whatever
wow like she really didn't want to hear
what i was saying and the judge says
fine oh my gosh that's so sad that's so
sad she'll send him her ruling in the
mail and then i'm like yeah my ex
said that she's working
how could she be working and get cash
eight
you can't work and get cash aid
and she the judge was like well
i looked into that she's not working
she's taking the classes
that dpss require her to take i don't
know what she told me she was work she's
like well you have to take that up with
custody i'm like all right okay what all
right i looked into that did you hear
that the judge was like well i looked
into that she's not working she's taking
the classes
that dpss require her to take the same
judge that said that she doesn't know
about the custody case because she's
just sitting in is the judge that's now
saying that she's looked into the
classes that the mother's taking why is
that because if the mother's taking
classes then she might need some help
you see what's going on i tell her the
judge said johnny
i've been knowing this girl 10 years she
never had or tried to get a job
i said she she's willing she's well
enough and able enough to work she just
that's the thing oh my gosh
there are so many females that don't
want to work
ladies
i'm not saying that you need to work 80
hours a week some crazy [ __ ] like that i
know props to the guys that do it
i like to have work life balance um
but
20 hours
if he's getting the kids half the time
you have time to go to work
i don't
do it
and i was like if we
continue to provide her with
with
a free way out she never will go look
for a job and the judge was just like
didn't want to hear what i was saying
now do you see what la is doing let me
give you another quick lead attorney
legal lesson when lawyers are in court
talking to judges talking to you members
of the jury what we are constantly doing
while we're talking is we're taking your
temperature we're reading your body
language we need to know if you agree or
disagree with what we're saying if
you're on our side then we can just shut
up but if we feel that you're not on our
side yet then we need to keep talking we
need to keep going we need to keep
making different arguments to convince
you that we're right la is taking the
temperature of the room and he's noticed
that things might not be going in his
favor so what does he do he makes an
excellent policy argument your honor
i've been knowing this girl 10 years she
never had or tried to get a job i said
she's well enough and able enough to
work she just won't do it if we continue
to provide her with a free way out she
never will go look for a job he's saying
listen this lady has not worked in the
past decade she can work but she won't
work if she gets more handouts she will
never look for a child in fact the whole
reason that they're in court is because
the child support stopped in the first
place and she applied for government aid
instead of applying for a job the
arguments that this man is making are
the same arguments that attorneys would
make this is fantastic to see and the
crazy thing is the judge asked me how do
i contribute when my daughters is with
her jesus christ and i was like well
janna that's a that's a two-way question
because how do she contribute when my
daughters is with me
and she's like that's not what i ask mic
drop mic drop
so i said
i contribute by calling my daughters
speaking to him frequently
you know and she was like hmm okay
but but anyway listen sometimes the
judge will ask you a question that lets
you know the whole case is over the
whole case this is one of those
questions when i heard him say this guys
as an attorney who's been in and out of
courtrooms for the last 19 years i knew
that it was over and this is what you
get he has joint legal joint physical
custody of his children and the judge
asked him how he contributes to his ex's
home when his children over there it
doesn't make any sense these judges take
advantage of you go to hearings where
there are no attorneys and see how these
judges speak to you it is clear to me
that he's about to be railroaded
so why do you guys think that the system
is so rigged against men like why is
this allowed
and what policies do you think would
prevent this in the future let me know
in the comments i contribute by calling
my daughter speaking to him frequently
that's a perfect response perfect
everything he said is lead attorney
approved like a month later
i get a letter in the mail
they reopen their child support case
they was gonna start garnishing my way
just immediately there you go
six hundred dollars every month what
guys thank god
six oh
oh goodness that is so much money
i don't know what to say if you are a
man and if you have kids this could
absolutely be you a hundred percent guys
this is a normal case that's the worst
thing about it this isn't a case where
some judge went crazy this is not a case
where you can point to la and said he
did all of these things wrong this is
what happens i've been seeing this for
almost 20 years this is it guys you
cannot tell me that there is a place for
this the reason that this video
resonated with me is because i see it i
see it all the time and i am sick of it
that's why i'm using time out of my life
to make a video about it this video is
so important to me because you need to
know what is happening in courts all
over the nation you point to one
thing that this man did wrong to deserve
to be in this situation point to one and
if he doesn't deserve this then why do
we have a system that puts him in these
circumstances and the point is it's not
just him that's the whole point of this
video it's thousands and thousands of
men each and every year so i'm liking
this about a [ __ ] now keep in mind this
was in was in march i called the the
worker the caseworker the the case
manager can't get back in court they're
not seeing no cases right now they'll
let me know so i filed f300 paper and i
think f355 to modify my my custody order
they sent me a letter with a court date
i think it was in it was in uh it was in
april something then before the court
date i get another letter saying that
they was postponing it until july july
i get another another uh letter saying
that they only send certain court cases
in my matter it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be seen until further notice he filed to
reopen his case in march but you
remember what happened in march of last
year right you remember what was going
on in the nation all the courthouses
were closed down and that's not child
support's fault the courts should have
closed no one knew what was going on at
the time it was crazy so he refiles but
he can't get back into court because
it's closed down and and that's
reasonable that's just bad luck so i
call a court i speak to somebody and the
lady said that uh yeah they wasn't
seeing because of
whatever whatever and i'm like then when
will i be able she was like our website
an update once we able to take court
cases in in the meantime you would have
to have a re-subpoena and you would have
to pay the fees and file again and i'm
like wait a minute so this man is
getting penalized
for his ex lying and she's rewarded for
it
what kind of system does that i don't
know
anything about law legal i worked at a
law firm one summer
i wanted to be a lawyer actually when i
was younger and then i worked at a law
firm for a summer and
i thought no
that
looks like way too much reading for me
but
it's the ever the average people that
should know about stuff like this
because those are the people that vote
and it's crazy that
this goes so under the radar i haven't
even got seen for the first fees i just
paid
she's like well you have to pay the fees
over it refile and re-subpoena her and
i'm like but
my services wasn't met the first time i
i paid for everything and i supponded
her
but anyway didn't get nowhere say
do you hear this are you listening to
this his court case keeps getting
rescheduled even though he's paid all of
the fees because of the court closures
fine that's understandable but but now
they're telling him that he needs to
refile and repay the fees all over again
this is completely unacceptable
members of the jury let me explain
something to you you're you're walking
down the street and you get mugged
you'll get a letter from the courthouse
telling you to show up to court your
girl will say hey you got a letter from
the courthouse you're all what's it say
she says well it says that you have to
show up to testify against the guy who
mugged you you say well where do i show
up she says well the courthouse now i
have a question for you why do you have
to show up at the courthouse you have to
show up at the courthouse because that's
where the guy that mugged you will stand
trial the courthouse is where you will
get justice in the case with la though
he was mugged by the courthouse the
courthouse itself stole that man's money
they have a record of him paying they
have the file they say nope that money's
gone file again this is outrageous this
man was lied on to get him back in court
the judge reopened the case based on
that lie and now the courthouse itself
is stealing his money how many times
does a man need to get victimized do you
not see this
listen no one cares what if during what
happened last year la had lost his job
now he can't pay the 600 in child
support then what oh they suspend his
license california puts a 10 interest on
the child support debt they put him in
jail take that man's freedom away and
for what and i mean if you really just
want to take it there if he loses his
job based on what was going around in
the nation and he can't pay his child
support they're gonna take his stimulus
checks from it but the stimulus checks
were to help the people who lost their
jobs based on what was going around in
the nation and now he can't get it do
you see how they're coming after you
every chance that they get and let me
say this talking about this why is that
it doesn't make any sense
like why is that stimulus checks when
people say that these stimulus checks
should be withheld from fathers who owe
child support they don't realize or they
don't care that many of these fathers
are great fathers like l.a many of these
fathers who owe child that's true
that because when
i was growing up
if i heard that someone wasn't paying
child support i i would definitely look
at them in a negative light
because you don't have all the facts you
don't understand the entire situation
and it seems like a selfish thing to do
but you don't think about
is a lot of these fathers are in their
lives
i don't know it's crazy the more i watch
manosphere content the more
i feel bad for men i'm not even gonna
lie i'm like
going through life as a female i would
not trade it sorry guys oh support
actually have 50 50 custody of their
children but no one cares
so i said okay
how to can i
how can i win
it's obvious that
without a lawyer they're not trying to
hear nothing you saying
so how can i win
i got a joint custody and i'm still
paying child support
and guys this part right here is what
got me this part right here is what hurt
me he is absolutely right and when he
said it i felt this man is saying
nothing but the truth members of the
jury which one of you can say that this
is fair and just treatment of a solid
father who has 50 50 custody of his kids
you hear all the time that men need to
pay their child support that men who
don't pay are deadbeats what are they
talking about if la loses his job
because of these national events and
can't pay that 600
every month even though he has joint
legal joint physical custody of his
children is he now a deadbeat guys this
is too much please hit the like button
so youtube will share this goddamn damn
video okay i'm gonna end that here
because he goes on to talk about
picking the right girl
and
i'm gonna tell you guys a story
i played volleyball from a young age
right it seems random but it's not and
there was a girl on my volleyball team
that
i put this clearly was crazy um like
very obvious always had a hot temper in
the gym was always the girl you know
having a fit
cake caked on makeup whatever but guys
lined up
to date her because she was hot
don't get me wrong
i understand guys are visual
you could be blinded by a hot a hot
chick
but
don't
don't forget to look at a girl's
character because
girls are sneaky and girls are conniving
and girls will take advantage of you if
you let them so
don't do that let me know in the
comments if you guys want more videos
like this and let me know what policies
you think need to be put in place to
make
the child support system a little bit
more fair
don't forget to subscribe talk to you
guys next time